[Music]
ah that music Game of Thrones fans
doesn't get your heart pumps jugs it is
back this Sunday on HBO a camera and all
eyes gonna be on kit Harry I mean he's
right at the top of the fan favorite
list that's for sure but something
explosive is gonna happen this season
key players will start joining forces
and Carla Steele worked very hard to get
some clues out of kit
how exciting was it for you to get to
work with some of the cast that you
hadn't worked with before I think that's
the thing I enjoy most I got to work
with some friends some very very close
friends who I've never worked with and I
loved it one of those friends could be
Emilia Clarke the mother of dragons
herself paparazzi in Spain snap pics of
them filming together the fans have been
so excited about seeing the photos of
Jon Snow and Khaleesi on the beach that
was the most annoying thing this season
I think was the paparazzi's drones that
were flying around I think we've all got
very upset and angry that people would
want to spoil a TV show in that way for
people so I'm not even I know if those
photos out there but I'm not even gonna
confirm whether me and Daenerys me yeah
or it could be a faked it could be a set
up and kids not kidding he says he
actually shot 15 hours of fake zooms to
throw the paparazzi off the scent
shooting for the eighth and final season
starts this fall and the 30 year old may
have a hard time swiping a souvenir from
the set
are there any prompts on set that you
have your eye on to steal think you're
like I'm taking that there's only one
that I've ever wanted
I want my sword the first season they
went yeah yeah yeah cause and as the
seasons went on and the show became more
more popular and that swords value went
up and up it becomes slowly quieter
about it and that's why I'm hinting more
and more I'm like no seriously I want
that sword no like I'm just I steal it
just like you stole rose-less Lee's
heart now they fell in love while she
was on the show but thank goodness for
face time because they do it every
chance they get even when Game of
Thrones is shooting all over the world
[Music]
Oh